- Okay.
Hello everyone.
Thanks for joining our session.
I actually wanted to double thank you guys
because let's face it, it's the third day
of the summit already.
It's Las Vegas, it's late evening.
The happy hours are already started.
We are already aware of that.
I mean, as Lady Gaga says,
You had millions of reasons
to ditch us, but I guess
you had your one good reason
to be here," and that's migration I guess.
By the show of hand, how many
of you are from overseas?
Do we have anybody from overseas?
Welcome, I assume the rest
of you are from the United States.
Do we have any locals from Las Vegas?
I mean this light doesn't let me, anyways.
Welcome.
I mean, how many of you have
planned your trips in person?
You did it yourself.
Really only you, so I guess the rest
of you just had the luxury
of an executive assistant
doing the traveling for you.
Good for you.
I'm really impressed.
I mean, regardless of
who did this for you,
there are a few things that you needed
to clear out before being here.
First off, you needed to
know where you're going,
why you're going, when are you going,
how are you going?
How much money are you allowed to spend?
What's your budget?
Do you need any accommodations?
All of those answers,
regardless of whether you're planning
for a fairly short trip like this
or a rather longer journey,
need some decent answer
before we can actually have a meaningful
and successful meeting.
And today I, Sassan
Hajrasooliha, a senior,
AWS solutions architect,
specialized in I mean
infrastructure, modernization
and migration along with my peers,
Mangesh Budkule
and Adi Simon are going to show you
how you can get data-driven answers
to the same questions
when it comes to your digital journey
of migrating your workloads
to AWS with the focus
of Microsoft based workloads.
Okay, first we're going
to talk a little bit
about a generic portfolio
of what a typical
migration would look like.
We going to talk about discovery.
Then we are going to go
deeper into each categories
of portfolio of workloads
that you might be running
on your environment.
The demos are all blended.
We're going to have an engaging session,
so let's hit it.
You guys here because most probably
your organization is one
of these organizations
that still have workloads
that includes this 70% of workloads
that are still running on premises.
Why you wanna move to the clouds?
Again, you could have a million
reasons to move out there.
The latest addition to
this mix is embracing a AI
ML in general and
generative AI in particular.
But we know that you need
answers to the question
that I brought up again,
and we know that those answers,
they're not easily got.
The main thing is resource scarcity.
That resource could be human resources,
it could be budget,
it could be timing, it
could be the skillset.
We know that you need
to be able to figure those out
before you can have a
successful migration.
I mean, when you look back at the journey
that people have already
been gone through,
you see some milestones out there.
First, I mean, in the late nineties
and early 2000s,
everybody was just running
their workloads in their
server room in their office.
Then they decided to embrace
the commercial data centers
and the concept of co-location.
Moving forward to 2005,
it was the early days
of cloud, people started
to embrace more of what cloud had
to offer and we had different
milestones moving forward
and right now our milestone is GenAI,
moving to the cloud for AI
and by AI, maybe in 2023
when you were thinking
about GenAI with your projects,
you were just thinking of
having your prompt somewhere,
getting some feedback,
getting some recommendations
from your model,
and then implementing it manually.
Then came 2024.
Now you could get better,
more contextual prompts
to the AI model using systems
like RAG and augmented retrievals
and more streamline experience,
but still everything was manual
and now head to 2025.
It just we want the AI
to not just tell us what to do,
we want it to do things for us
of course under our supervision
and under our security guidelines,
and that's what agentic AI mean,
and we are going to show
you how we can leverage
that for our migration project.
I mean for a typical journey,
one of the trivial questions
that you already know,
the answer is where am I coming from?
You already know where you are,
but in a digital journey like migration,
that is actually a question
that needs to be answered.
What are we migrating and why do I have,
and that would be the
concept of discovery.
Our primary go-to mechanism to answer
that question has always been
and still is, this mechanism
that we call optimization
and licensing assessment
or OLA as the acronym goes.
Through this process,
us as AWS along with our
partners, we would come
to your environment,
we'll scan your
environment with our tools.
We see the relationships
that you had with different vendors
and we would come up
with recommendations,
including licensing recommendations
from different vendors,
whether it's a good choice for you
to do to use the bring
your own license scenario versus
going and purchasing license included.
These are the answers
that we will have for you
if you go through the OLA.
If you're interested in this topic,
we have some resources
that we are going to share with you
towards the end of the session.
The question is, is there an
alternative way of doing it?
And the answer is yes.
I mean, you probably have already
heard about this service
that we put a lot of emphasis on
and it's called AWS Transform.
It's an umbrella of services
and modules that will
help you at each step
of your way towards your migration.
It can actually help you
with assessments as well.
You would feed it your inventory data.
Many of the common and
popular formats are supported,
but it's a generative AI.
Most probably if there's the format
that you understand
most probably our GenAI
will understand it as well,
so it gets your inventory data
and based on the other supporting data
that you possibly can fit into it,
you will get some insight into it.
Let's actually see what
it works in action,
how it works in action,
so starting with the familiar face,
your vCenter, I have a cluster
of two SESXI hosts with a bunch
of virtual machines running on them.
They're hosting a plethora of applications
with different environments
like for example, this one
is a travel expense application
with three tiers of
architectural element into it.
I'm going to use AWS discovery tool.
This is our own tool for discovery.
The first time I'm going to run it,
it requires a new password.
I'm going to put my password here.
This is the interface for it.
The first thing I'm going to do is to,
give it access to my
vCenter environment so
that they can inventory
my virtual environment.
The moment I type it in,
as you see at the bottom,
the agent starts scanning the environment,
but that I want more.
I want dependency mapping data
as well as SQL versions
that I can later on optimize
and this is why I'm
going to give credentials
to the guest via virtual machines
so that they can go deeper
and talk to the virtual
machines themselves.
Again, the moment that I do that,
the database discovery
and network discovery agents,
they'll kick in too,
and as you see each one
of them has different refresh
cycle every hour for VMs,
every 24 hour for databases
and every 15 seconds to be able to grab
that network dependency mapping data.
Already, we got some information here.
Let's see what we have for our inventory.
This is the same environment
that you saw through the vCenter.
Some of them, as you see, they have errors
because the credentials were different,
but for whatever reason,
we can actually download
the inventory in the zip file.
If you look at the name, it says 28 days.
That's the how long we recommend that you
keep running this tool.
Logging into AWS Transform,
this is identity center
plethora of identities
providers are supported.
This is the front page
for our AWS Transform.
As you see at the bottom,
we have some customer testimonies
and some found what's new on those topics.
First thing we need to do
is to create a workspace,
so workspace is just a space
that holds onto all the
activities you need to do
for a specific migration project.
Okay?
We created our workspace.
Now we go in, as you see,
we have some suggested
prompts on the right
with the categories of migration tasks
that you can select.
I can directly type in the category,
the action that I want
to do to the model
and it will open up a proper job for me.
There it is, suggesting, I accept this,
suggesting for the job names and all that,
and here's where the
actual action happens.
Humans in the loop.
Now it's asking me for the inventory data
that I got from the previous step.
I'm going to upload my zip file
and I'm going to choose
my destination region
as the possible target for my migration
and hit analysis.
While it's processing my data,
I can see that.
I can see what the model
is doing through the workload.
It's showing me what the model is doing.
We have the artifacts,
everything that we fed into the model
as well as whatever the model generated
for us will be in the artifacts.
There are some collaboration
features within AWS Transform,
and of course the main
panel will be the job panel.
Each step that is done,
there's a checkbox.
The yellow means human in the loop
and this one is still
working, while it's working.
I can ask for anything for status updates,
for example, in this example.
It's giving me some example that these
are the actions that have been done.
These are the left ones
and of course in the middle this is done.
Let's see what this assessment
has provided for us.
The first thing is a PDF report
of an executive summary pretty much
of what is our prediction of the savings,
do we get on the cloud.
What are an overview
of our recommendations,
all that you need, nice
human readable format.
You'll get the same information as part
of a PowerPoint presentation
as well that you can use
as a basis for your presentations.
If you're a partner to your customers
or to somebody in your hierarchy,
all those data is already populated there.
You can use that.
And the meat of our
assessment is the casella spreadsheet.
Here you would see
that all those inventory
data that we fed into,
now we have a line by
line analysis of them,
the server name, the storage
attached to them, the specs,
the recommendation that we have
for you on which instance like to move it
and of course estimate
of each one line-by-line
with a separation of
licensing versus compute.
All those will remain
in your workspace even when your job
is done and you can come back to it
and use these artifacts again when
you're creating other
jobs for the next steps
of your migration.
As you see here, the dependency mapping
and all that, we can use them later on for
other steps of our migration.
Great.
Now we know that we have
discovered our environment
and we know that our workloads
most probably fall under one
of these categories with regards
to specifically Microsoft based workloads.
Servers and Vms, anything generic,
you think about your
infrastructure servers as well
as generic application servers.
If you are a Microsoft shop, 95% of chance
that you are using active
directory as your identity
and access management.
SQL databases has always
been the database of choice
for Microsoft based development.
Same thing with .NET,
but when it comes to windows
and web applications,
you might already be on your pathway
for modernization,
maybe through some
containerization features
that you see out there
and the file storage.
For those of you who are
familiar with our terminology,
we have this concept of 7Rs of migration,
of course, rehost, just lifting
and shifting again to another host,
re-platform, using the same technology
but maybe offloading
some management elements
to a third party provider in our case AWS
and refactoring means
just decomposing the application
and creating, again,
new to be able to grab as much
of the cloud native features as possible.
Now let's dive deep into each category.
First one, servers and VMs.
By the show of hands,
how many of you are not using VMware?
That's what I, oh, actually we have two.
That's great.
Okay, so for the rest of you who do,
we have plenty of sessions covering
this new service we have called
Amazon Elastic VMware service or EVS.
For this session, it's just enough to say
that we will give you
the ESXi host in your
account and then you can use
the technologies you're already
familiar with to migrate
your VM virtual machines to AWS.
We're not going to go
deeper than this into this.
The generic service that
we have for migration
and for the lift shift.
It has been around for a while
and it has been called application
migration service or MGN.
This is a service that installs
a little agent on your source servers.
Then it transfers blocks of zeros
and wants to your staging
environment in your own account.
When you're ready for the cutover,
either test cutover
or final production cutover,
we will hydrate EC2 instances
based on the launch templates
you define for each server
and then you'll have a replica
of your on-premises
servers running on AWS.
There is a minor revision to that as well.
In that case for the on-prem environment,
if you're using VMware, you don't need
to install agents
individually on each server,
but rather you rely on a central appliance
to do the replication for you
and we rely on VMware's
snapshot technologies
to get those deltas of
zeros and ones to us.
Regardless of which one you would use,
MGN is just the engine.
When you are doing the migration at scale,
you need to be able to
orchestrate to do wave planning
and make sure that the
dependencies are met.
So far, these were the services
that you would be using
to track your scaled migration project,
but now we've taken all those experiences
and has put them in the AWS Transform
for VMware migration category
and our Mighty Mangesh here,
will go deeper into that.
- Thank you Sassan.
Hello everyone, Mangesh here.
So let's continue the
server migration journey.
So we are living in a
artificial intelligence era,
so speed matters and how we work.
Large migrations are complex,
takes time, it's error prone
and require a lot of
efforts and coordination.
So raise your hand if you believe
the agentic AI has a
potential to transform your
traditional migration processes.
Wait, you're right.
With that, I'm excited
to talk about our first agentic AI service
AWS Transform for VMware,
which seems simplify moving your servers
from your environment to Amazon EC2.
With minimum human
oversight using our
goal-driven specialized agents,
which we have built with the 70 plus years
of our experience, this
new UI provides you
more flexibility
and AI first shared driven
experience throughout your
migration process.
So let's see how it works.
So flexibility starts with
you are onboarding the transform
using all your own choice
of identity, whether it's Okta, Intra
or maybe AWS Identity center.
It has a key four phases,
starts with the discovery
where you can provide
your VMware information using your
choice of tools, whether it's RV tools
or maybe if you are using
a partner like a Cloudamize
or modelizeIT or the
Sassan already explain
our tool called AWS Transform
from discovery tool,
that is what we recommend you.
Once Transform agent has this all analysis
of your environment,
then that agent will group
your servers into different waves
and applications.
Now you can work with
the agent to guide them
to group them based off your business
or technical constraint like example,
application owner base functions
department or maybe OS or IP subnets.
Transform agent also
understand your source network
and it translate that into
AWS specific networking
components like VPC subnet and more
and provide you the cloud formation
and CDK template which you can download,
make the appropriate changes as you want
and you can do your deployment.
If you are using third party tools
for the firewall like Cisco
ACI or maybe a FortiGate
or Palo Alto, which is
normally customer use
or maybe NSH driven your
networks, you can input
that information in Transform
and for the more context.
Transform agent also
give you the different
design options when you deploy,
whether it's a hub and spoke model
or it's a isolated VPC
and now it supports
the multiple flexible IP address mapping
along with the different
multiple accounts deployment
and that is very much required
for large migrations.
Once Transform agent
has these all networking information
and waves and planning and everything,
it goes to the next phase,
which is a migration phase
where it will orchestrate
end-to-end your migration using
behind the scene AWS MGN
service which Sassan explain.
Now Transform can migrate
your servers not only from VMware
but if you have a hyperV, KVM
or maybe your physical servers,
it can do that for you.
Important thing is about human-in-loop.
It's very important where
it creates that balance
between end-to-end automation
and human oversight so
that you can provide the user
input on every critical task
throughout this migration process
and it creates that unified
web collaborative experience so
that your teams enable
to do the streamlined communication,
resolve the blockers quickly
and award this coordination delays,
which are normally comes
across all large migrations.
Now with that, do we have
any alternative method
to do the large migrations?
So as I told, large migrations
are complex time taken
but also large migrations communicate
with different data sources,
different services, tools.
They have a number of pre-migration tasks,
post migration tasks.
These are the normal scenarios actually.
So how you work on that,
we have already one proven
service call cloud migration factory,
which customers are using
to migrate thousands
of servers at scale at a time, right?
But question here is can we take this
to the next level considering
we are now living in a AI era,
so how we work is matters most.
Example I'm saying
can I,
ask AI agent to analyze
my flow chart, migration flow chart,
which I have in my mind, right?
And ask agent to analyze this work
with the cloud migration factory
and create these all pipelines
and automation jobs to do
the end-to-end migration
and I will be as a human
and expert will make sure
that agent is doing right.
Yes, it is possible
with KIRO CLI as a agent,
now in this case my migration
agent assistant can work
with cloud migration factory
to create all these pipelines
and everything which I draw in my picture
as a migration, right?
Which I want to do, with
the help of MCP server,
which is a model context protocol
server which has all the
required tools to communicate
with the cloud migration factory
and cloud migration factory
between if you see the automation
engine that is nothing
but what, that is already prebuilt
automation using MGN.
So you can understand engine
services now so critical,
which Sassan explain it's used
in all our services,
it's a behind the scene.
Can you take this enhance more?
Yes, you can take the advantage
of AWS Transform now,
which I think Sassan
explain as our assessment
to do the assessment for
the large data centers
or you can use the wave planning
and everything out of that
and then import that into
a cloud migration factory to consider.
Now you may have a question,
what about the pre-task
and pro-task, right?
So you can take the advantage
of our Amazon bedrock agent core
where you can build
your own migration agent
to handle the task for you.
Example, ticket creation,
Jira stories or maybe
after migration DNS updates
or many more things which
are email communication.
All these things you can handle
through our secure platform agent core.
So now let's see this in action.
Okay.
So this is the WordPress application
which we want to migrate, okay?
This is just a servers, multiple servers.
One of them is obviously
WordPress servers.
This is just on premises to AWS.
This is the cloud foundation factory,
which I already deployed to save the time,
but this is a blank factory
if you see it's a zero
zero server, zero
applications, everything.
I launched my Kiro as my AI agent
and now this is the MCPs tool
which is having all the tools
for the cloud migration factory,
right, which it will use.
This is the agent core where I built
migration agents like for one
for ticket creation,
one for email communication,
and this is the flowchart
I was talking about like there are
some manual tasks, automated tasks
and simple flow chart
starting with the ticket
and ending with the notification
in between migration steps.
Now this is the prompt I gave to AI agent.
Go and analyze this JPG file,
which I have shown you before,
and do the job for me,
create the pipelines, work
with the cloud migration
factory and work with that.
So that is what exactly
now it is trying to do now.
It is creating that all
pipeline behind the scene
with the cloud migration
factory using MCP protocol.
As you can see now it is doing that
and then it will also
ask you for the inventory
of your servers, which you
can take from Transform
or your own inventory in the CVS format.
You can give it to that.
In our case, we have three applications,
five servers and two waves created.
So if you go now cloud
migration factory UI,
you see that two waves,
five migration and five servers
and three applications.
This is the UI,
but you can ask the status from Kiro also,
like agent, what is my
status of the migration
and now you can see
that it will also try to create a wave one
because that is the one
I'm showing in the demo
to migrate the WordPress servers, right?
This is the UI of the
cloud migration factory
where you can control the teams also,
but we want to control through AI.
So if you go back now, yes, you can ask
what is the status of my migration?
It will go, but if you see
that migration is not started, why?
Because there was one
manual process previously
that ticket creation,
it's asking provide the ticket,
so it's understand
manual versus automated.
Now we are providing that, yeah,
I have a ticket, now it's going
to go all follow my flow chart
and do the migration
for me behind the scene using MGN.
So if you see now in the UI
that this is installed,
the replication agents
behind the scenes started
the block level migration
and step by step it will follow
all the process test instant creation,
test and then cut over
and then deploy the production instances.
All it will do for me example,
if you see there were
two new migrator servers are there
and now I can just ask
what is the status there?
Everything looks good, it's demo,
but there may be failures also,
you can ask a possible,
now you can see all the pipeline here.
Again, the main motive
is what we don't want
to go multiple UIs,
cloud migration factory,
then MGN, I just want to check everything.
You can see notification
and I got the notification.
This is the application
from new migrated server
and this is overall status.
So this is how fast you can work now,
with the AI, right, you
can ask these questions
and in this it's a everything works fine,
but in case reality maybe it fail,
it will not able
to install the agents.
You can work back and forth with AI agent
and ask why it's failed
and it can fix it using
natural language communication.
That is the main intention of data.
So again, we have covered
how you can do the server migration.
We have multiple ways to do that.
I will suggest work backwards
from your own requirements,
whether it's a technical and business
and see what solution best work for you.
Example AWS Transform, maybe
Cloud Foundation Factory
or maybe our partners and services tools.
Okay.
So let's see now change the topic
to core service active directory.
How many of you are
using active directory?
Almost maybe all right, this is the most
used application across industry
and very critical application,
we are thinking about the migration.
So let's see what are the
design options we have.
We have our native three options on AWS.
The first is a self-managed
EC2 domain controllers.
When I say self-managed
means in this model,
you are responsible for managing
this domain controller,
whether it's a managing, monitoring
or maintaining throughout
the lifecycle of the DCs.
The key point on DCs,
if you can extend your
own domain to my EC2.
If you have 50,000
or maybe 100,000 of users,
you can extend that easily
with the AD replication
and start giving authentication
to your migrated application.
This is the fastest
way you can start doing
and most of the customers do this.
Second option we have is a
AWS managed AD has managed,
this is managed by us.
We deploy active directory for you
and behind the scene domain
controllers so you don't require
to worry about the undifferentiated heavy
lifting of the domain controller.
We manage that for you
and this is an enterprise ready service.
So it comes with the seamless integration
with AWS applications,
maybe announced features
like directory sharing
or replication and everything.
But the key point on these services,
when you deploy the active directory,
you deploy as a single
for a single domain new, new
single forest single domain.
That means what?
You cannot extend your existing
domain to managed AD.
So if you want to provide
the authentication you need
to create a trust
relationships like one way
or two way trust relationship
depends upon your use case.
Third is active AD connector.
AD connector is not active directory.
This is like a gateway
or maybe I will say simple term
it's like a bridge
between your on-premises active directly
and AWS specific application
which support the AD
connector to provide
the authentication and lookups.
This is one-to-one relationship.
So you may end up deploying
multiple AD connector,
just make sure that you use
the unit service account
to avoid the blast radius issues.
Now these options are used
by our customers all the time.
I across the segment,
whether it's a government, education,
finance, life science, healthcare,
I'm supporting these customers
to deploy the active
directory from long time
and we get the feedback.
They're looking for a
solution, managed solution
and AWS which is a flexible
and easy to maintain
and also get the managed
experience like the managed AD,
but they can able to
extend their own domain
to managed AD,
which is not possible right now, right?
So that they don't require
to do the trust relationships
or maybe actual migration
from their own domain
to manage AD, which is a big project
as you guys know already,
it's so difficult
to do the AD migration.
With that as you guys
know, most of our services
and features comes from your feedback.
So I'm excited to talk about
our new service AWS-Managed
AD Hybrid Edition.
Now in this service,
you can extend your existing domain
to manage AD hybrid edition so
that you can take the
advantage of managed experience
because we manage the domain
controllers this for you, right?
And same thing like EC2,
you can quickly start
giving the authentication
to your migrated applications.
How you design this, though,
if you have a domain controllers
on premises, you can just
extend that as a additional domain
controllers on Managed AD.
Just make sure it is onboarded
with the system manager
is one of the prerequisite.
If you have a EC2 domain controllers,
you just extend
that now to hybrid AD.
So, but in this case,
hybrid AD domain controllers,
which is your domain
only is managed by us, but EC2
and on premises is managed by you.
So it's a co-management now between us.
So let's see this in action,
how this works actually new service.
So if you see now
these are the two domain controls I
already migrated from my on-premises.
This is onboarded with the system manager.
This is important thing
to notice the OU structure.
You can see this is your
OU structure, right?
And these are self-managed
domain controllers by you.
This is the secret we need to create
because we need some access to your domain
to add the additional domain controller.
So we created the secret
and these are very specific names secret.
This is documented in our website.
These are needs to be the same names
and once your secrets are there,
your domain controllers are
onboarded with the system manager.
Now you see the new option here
in the managed AD hybrid edition
along with the normal our managed AD.
Provide all the domain information in DNS
networking is very
important behind the scene.
Provide all that.
Now you can see the two domain controllers
which we have provided,
which is minimum requirement,
minimum two, you need to
provide us to use that
for the additional domain
controller deployment.
And everything looks good but,
we are not installing hybrid AD directly.
We are creating the assessment.
Why?
Because we need to make sure
that whatever domain controllers you have
provided to us is healthy, working fine.
So behind the scene we are
going to check 38 tests.
We are going to run,
which is very simple AD specific test
like resolution replication
to make sure they are healthy.
And this assessment
we are going to use successful
as is another prerequisite
to create the hybrid domain controllers.
And now you have to provide
the service account.
You can see the service
account which we have created
and then once everything looks good,
all the information is good.
Now you can say that create
the hybrid directory.
So behind the scene
what we are going to do is now
we are going to deploy
the domain controllers for you
in our account obviously
and just going to manage by us.
And you can see now IP hyphen.
So the IP hyphen is
domain controller deployed
by us for your domain.
But managing and the OU structure
you can see now, new two
OUs are added, AWS reserve.
So that is what exactly managed
by us all other is your domain anyway
and two domain controllers by yourself
and total if you see now
there are four domain controllers.
So you can see the two are managed by you
and two are managed by us
under the co-management with this.
And if you go to the actual directory
and see that, you know,
all looks like successful everything
and assessment is also successful.
If you click now the domain you will see
this is a managed AD kind of experience
where you can see the application
management and all that.
So we did that managed experience now.
With that I will hand over to Adi
for the next journey over.
- Thank you Mangesh.
It's through active directory.
Now as part of customer's
migration journey,
the next workload
that is most commonly talked about are
database and application.
Can I get a raise of
hand if you run Microsoft
SQL Server today?
Okay, great.
Most of you.
Alright so my name is Adi, I'm gonna talk
to you about your database
layer and application layer.
Let's get started with SQL Server.
Okay, now let's try to understand
what are your options
to run SQL Server on AWS.
The first option is Re-host
onto SQL server on EC2.
Now this gives you the
most flexibility in terms
of SQL server additions,
SQL server versions,
and you have a very
familiar admin experience
and full control of your SQL server.
Now you can choose license included
or BYOL if you meet the
eligibility requirements.
But full control comes
with full responsibility.
That means you are responsible
for managing everything on EC2 except
for the physical infrastructure.
So what if you're thinking,
is there a way to offload
this operational overhead?
The answer is yes.
You can re-platform
to our managed database solution,
which is Amazon RDS
for SQL Server.
With this you get the managed experience.
We optimize the architecture
for you, AWS automates patching backup.
You also get the high availability
if you opt for multi-AZ
and license is also
included in this option.
We also have a third option called RDS
Custom for SQL server.
This is where if you have
a use case where you need
to access the operating system
to install things like
third party agents such
as your security agents,
your monitoring lock folder,
this can be done with RDS custom.
Now that you know what
is your destination when it comes
to SQL Server on AWS,
let's talk about the approaches
for you to get there.
What are the migration approaches?
I'm gonna present
to you four very common approaches
and the first one is
to use MGN application
migration service, which Sassan
and Mangesh have already talked about.
To do a full lift
and shift from your SQL
server, be it on-prem
or on RD clouds onto SQL server on EC2.
This does block level application,
so that means everything
including your database, operating system,
data, configurations,
they all come along onto EC2.
Very simple, good for lift and shift,
good for individual database.
The next approach is gonna
be very familiar for all
of your database administrators out there.
Native backup and restore.
So with this approach
what you do is you back up your SQL
server as usual, then you upload
the backup file onto our storage services
such as Amazon S3 or FSX.
Then you restore them onto either EC2 RDS
or RDS custom.
But one caveat of this is
that you gotta take into account downtime
because backup then restore
undoubtedly involves some downtime.
So what if you want an approach
that minimizes the downtime?
Well, if you run a
clustered environment today
and you are taking advantage
of built-in high
availability features such
as you are always on availability group,
failover cluster instance,
log shipping,
what you can do
is you can spin up an EC2 instance
with SQL server on it
and then add that
as additional node in
your existing cluster.
Let the node synchronize
all of your data comes along
and once you're ready you perform
a control failover on
your source database.
Finally, when you're ready you can
decommission your source database.
So this is great if you
run clustered environment,
but this only works
if you coming onto SQL Server on EC2.
But the upside is this can also double up
as your disaster recovery
approach or solution.
Now finally, the one
that gives you most flexibility
is DMS, Database Migration
Service allows you to achieve
continuous data replication.
CDC, change data capture
from your source database to any
of the options that
I've just talked about.
So you can come onto EC2 RDS, RDS custom
with minimal downtime.
So this is great for highly
available applications,
but when it comes to database migration,
it goes hand in hand with modernization.
If you run SQL Server today, I would guess
that you would run it
on Microsoft's Windows server.
Is there a way to save on licensing costs,
at least on the Microsoft
Windows server side?
Yes there is.
With reperforming a system,
this is a scripting tool,
it allows you to export
your SQL server on Windows server
and restore it onto EC2 Linux.
So you save on Windows licensing cost,
but SQL Server itself is still quite
expensive in terms of license.
So what if you're thinking
about moving the database,
modernize it to open source
alternative such as MySQL.
or more commonly PostgreSQL
such as on Aurora.
You can use database migration
service to migrate the data,
but before you do
that you need to convert the schema
and we have a tool for that
as well, as part of DMS,
we have SCT schema conversion
tool that allows you
to convert your SQL server
schema onto the PostgreSQL
equivalent of or any
database of your choice.
But up until now you have
to convert this manually using SCT then
orchestrate DMS manually.
And what about your application code?
Now, modernizing database
without touching the application
is considered a breaking change
for your application, right?
So you're gonna make sure
that you tweak your application
to make it work with PostgreSQL.
Up until now you have
to orchestrate all this manually.
But with that I'd like
to introduce to you AWS Transform
for SQL server modernization
that allows you
to use the generative AI to orchestrate
and streamline all of
these proven migration
and modernization tools
to modernize your database
and application layer
from Microsoft SQL Server
to our open square SQL.
Okay, let's see this in action.
So as you saw from Sassan's demo,
the entry point
to AWS Transform is to
create a workspace, right?
And you can create jobs
within the workspace.
The job that we are interested
in is under this category
called Windows Modernization
and we are gonna need
to select the secret server
modernization option to create this job.
Once the job is created, you can see
that on the left hand side
you really got a guided
experience all the way from prerequisites
to the actual wave run.
This is an interactive experience.
You can converse with the agent
and if you look at the prerequisites,
it gives you clear guidelines.
Now for AWS Transform to
work with your database,
it's gonna need to access your database,
it's gonna need a user
for it to use to log in.
So this is our source database.
We have a few tables
and we have a user here.
This user is going to be
stored in Secrets Manager
and we are gonna tag it
in a very specific way
so AWS Transform can work with it.
Within our database,
we have a few tables as I mentioned
and if I do a select statement here,
you can see that we have
some data in our table.
On the application side,
this is an an entity
framework SQL server provider,
and this is a web application
that resembles a bookstore.
Okay, now back in AWS Transform
in the prerequisites, it tells you
how you should tag your secrets
that contains your database credentials.
So make sure that you tag it exactly.
This is documented on our website.
And as for the code, make sure
that you have got code
connections ready set up
onto your repository.
This can be GitHub, GitLab,
Bitbucket, Azure, DevOps.
Now establish the connection
to your database secret
and the code connection
from AWS Transform.
Once you approve that,
it will make sure to validate
that all of the access is okay,
IM rules are okay,
and then it will move
on to discover your resource.
As you can see, it has
successfully identified
that there is one database
through this secret
that it can access and it has also access
and found success with the repositories
that is associated with this database.
Okay, now after it's done,
then it's gonna move on
to the assessment phase
where it's gonna look at the complexity
of your database and application.
So it's gonna look at all
of your database objects,
determine its complexity, look at
how your application access the database,
making sure that it's able
to do the wave planning which comes next.
Now after the assessment is finished,
you get a downloadable report.
One of the aspect
that you can download is the CSV file
that contains a summary
of what you have in your database.
A well formatted PDF report
is presented to you as well.
On the application side,
you see your repositories,
complexity rating,
and high level lines of code count.
Once that is okay, you will move
on to the wave planning phase.
Now I've only got one
application and repository here,
but if you have got multiple,
the wave planning means
that it will actually
do application and database grouping.
So make sure human-in-the-loop,
make sure that you review
this before you hit okay,
because once you do so it will move on
to the actual wavefront.
The first task in the
wavefront is schema conversion.
And you can get a Transform
to create a new database for you
or you can select an
existing database as target
as we do so here.
Once you confirm that this
is the database that you want
to write to hit okay
and under the hood,
this will orchestrate schema conversion
tool to convert your
schema from SQL Server
to our Aurora PostgreSQL.
Now if you head over to
PGSQL on the Postgres side,
we now have our bookstore schema
and if we expand that, all of the tables
that you saw on the SQL server
side are now present here.
But if I do a select statement,
there's no data in these
tables yet, which is natural
because that comes next.
Data migration, second step,
and you can also ask AWS Transform
to orchestrate data migration for you.
What they will do is under the hood,
instead of you manually
having to create tasks in DMS,
it will create and configure
the DMS task for you
to do the data migration.
Once the data migration is ready.
And if I select this table again,
I will now see all
of the data that looks
exactly the same as the data
that we have in the SQL Server side.
What's next?
The code, right?
So it's gonna need to look into your code,
it's gonna scan your code,
do actual changes to your code.
It's gonna write it into this new branch
that you can specify instead
of overriding your existing code, right?
So it's gonna change
the entity framework classes to make sure
that it works with the new database.
If you have embedded SQL
code in your application,
it will change that as well.
It will swap out the connection stream
to make it PostgreSQL connection stream.
It will also validate the application.
It will also resolve any bill errors.
If you have unit tests,
it will run the unit test for you.
Once that is done, as I mentioned earlier,
it will write the results
into this new target branch
and you get a nicely downloadable report.
This is quite frankly a detailed report.
You can go project by project.
You can even drill down
to individual file changes
within each project as
part of this report.
Now let us switch over
to our code repository.
You can see that we now have
this new branch created
by AWS Transform.
If we take a peek
at the code changes that it has done,
we can see that it has made all
of the necessary class mapping
from the entity framework side.
If you scroll down, you can see
that it has actually swapped
out the SQL server provider
with PostgreSQL provider
and it has also swapped
out the connection string
and links the connection string.
So if you externalize
your connection string,
which is best practice, it will find those
and it will swap out the
secret for you as well.
On the application side,
before I show the application,
I'm gonna make a tiny change
to the data on the PostgreSQL side to say
that this book title now
says 1002 instead of 1001
that you will see on
SQL server side to prove
that the application
is indeed talking to PostgreSQL, right?
So if I start this application now
and browse to the book,
it should now say 1002
instead of 1001.
So application is definitely
talking to PostgreSQL.
Now database, they don't
exist in isolation.
They go along with your application.
So let's talk a little bit
about your application.
If you're a Microsoft shop,
you might be running some Legacy .NET
framework application
with a mix of more modern cross
platform .NET application.
Most likely you run
this in Windows server,
maybe some Linux server
and you might have already
started your journey
towards containerization.
You might have already started using these
container technologies.
So what are your options
to run this on AWS?
If you need full OS level access,
you can run them on EC2
or Elastic Beanstalk.
If you need automated
patching, automated scaling,
if you're on VMware,
you can relocate your entire estate
to EVS, like what Sassan
have already touched on.
Now if you wanna run containers,
we have a lot of options.
ECS, which is quite simple,
but powerful orchestration platform, EKS,
if you wanna run Kubernetes,
if you run your containers
on Red Hat OpenShift,
you can continue to run it
on AWS on Rosa Red Hat OpenShift
on AWS, if you are on VMware Tanzu
you can run VMware Tanzu on Amazon EVS
or you can also refactor
to serverless event driven
functions such as Lambda.
So how do you get from
the left to the right?
Of course MGN,
but it's less common when
it comes to application.
If you have access to your source code,
you are most probably gonna
use your CICD pipeline
to deploy to these environments.
And Code Pipeline and Code Deploy can
facilitate this for you.
Now what if you want
to use this opportunity
to modernize as you migrate?
Let's say that you wanna
containerize re-platform running
on containers or you want
to refactor, re-architect
to embrace the more cloud
native architecture.
This is what traditionally
gets quite complex
because you have to manually
orchestrate each one
of these tool that solve one piece
of the puzzle, porting
a system for porting
after container, containerization.
If you wanna break down microservices,
you want to use another tool.
So now we have AWS Transform for .NET
that is really designed
for transforming .NET
framework application
and make it .NET Linux ready.
So this in combination with AWS Transform
for SQL modernization gives
you a full stack modernization
capability that is
assisted by generative AI.
We also have Q developer
and Kiro, which is our coding assistant
with Gentech AI capability.
Q developer is as available
as extension in most
of the popular ID and Kiro
is a full featured IDE
with advanced agentic capabilities such
as spectrum development and Agent Hooks.
So with that I will hand it
over back to Sassan to talk
to you about the next workload.
- Thank you Adi.
Well, the last
but not the least important one,
the file servers,
what are we going to do with them?
I mean this section will
be more really a review
of the options you already have.
First off, self-manage,
bring up your EC2, make sure
that you have proper tiers of EBS
and the size of the EC2
that will support your throughput
and transfer rates and the IOPS.
And you'll be good.
You want to offload some
of its management tests to us.
You would go to the FSX system,
if all you need is SMB
with Windows under the hood, then SMB,
I mean FSX four file servers
is the service to go.
And if you need to go beyond that,
meaning NFS protocol,
iSCSI, tiered storage
and controls as such,
then it would be Amazon FSX
for NetApp ontap, the service
that you'll be looking for.
How you can migrate to them,
you already have quite a few options.
We talk deeply about MGN
for the lift and shift.
Depending on the target
that you want to use,
you might actually be
able to leverage some
of the native services
in Windows environment
for example, the FSR
it has some integration capabilities
with our FSX for Windows system.
Or if you wanna go to EC2,
your other option could be
the storage replica component
of Windows servers.
I mean, and if it's
actually a very small one,
you can simply use Robocopy
or use a third party system
and just do a manual copy.
If it's too big to do it
over the network, ship it
to us from Snowcone all
the way to Snowmobile,
we ship you the device, a secure device,
you loaded the data, ship
it back securely to us
and then we will put it on
Amazon it's free for you.
And from there you can decide what
to do next with your data.
And of course,
the most straightforward
service that we have
for grabbing all this
data is AWS data sync.
Depending on what your
source environment is when,
what access protocol is supports SMB, NFS
or S3 compatible APIs,
we would get those objects
and we will sync it to our backend.
And then depending on
the target storage type
that you want your data to be,
we will just put it there for you.
Real quickly, before we go
to this summary, we just wanted
to make sure that you know,
there are some programs
and incentives available to you,
discuss these with your account managers
to see if there are ones
that you're eligible
for, but they are there
and we want you to be
able to leverage them
for your migration projects.
Overall our whole purpose
for this session was to make sure
that your takeaway is
that your questions might remain the same.
But now given the new tools
and generative AI based
tools that we have,
we have answers for you.
And we are by your side
as team of solutions architect,
account managers, CSMs,
and the wide network of
partners that we have,
we are here to help you make
your migration journey easier.
Specifically, you saw that how you
can now offload some
of your management to us
with the hybrid active directory service
that we have out there.
You already saw
a demo of wide capabilities
that AWS Transform provides
for you all the way along.
And of course we just talked
about the programs and incentive.
If there's only one slide that we want you
to take away from our session,
it would be this one.
Here is an exhaustive
and extensive list of resources
that will go deeper into every individual
subsection that we talk today.
We didn't dive deep
into VMware or MGN, those topics,
we have some resources,
some of them are from this reinvent
and right now they point you
to the catalog for you to attend.
And later on when we have
the sessions recorded on YouTube,
we will update this page
to have the YouTube recording
of all these footages along
with this one of course.
And you'll see some blogs,
some technical notes,
some training materials
through our skill builder.
So all of those we've combined here
and we want you to bookmark
and go deeper into them
if you're interested.
And with that, I wanted
to thank you again.